the kids who had managed to resist the
marshmallow they did much better in
school they did better in life and
that's that's what kind of kicked off
the modern self control movement I'm
Katherine mangu Ward and we're here
talking with John Tierney about his new
book willpower thanks for talking with
us John thank you for inviting me
why willpower what is it that called to
you about this subject
well I'd written a parody of self-help
books and I've read sort of recent ones
and the old ones and I found that there
been this for aggression that the books
used to actually offer useful advice and
then the recent ones got into this
believe it achieve it stuff and then I
heard about when I started writing a
science calling for the time I heard
about the work of Roy Baumeister who's
the guy who we discovered willpower and
he and other researchers found that the
willpower is this real source of mental
energy that it's like a muscle that gets
depleted they also found found that
self-control and willpower are really
the the trait to cultivate it and we
think that that it's psychology is best
hope for helping people and that's what
and that's what we're about is helping
people so one thing you write about is
decision fatigue I think we've probably
all felt that but can you kind of
describe what it is and and how it works
from a scientific perspective
what's your discover that willpower the
popularity of that is it it's something
that you used to resist temptation to
make yourself work and that's very true
but they also found that the same energy
is used in making decisions simply
deciding whether they're you know what
to have for lunch you know what to do
with the meeting all these things
deplete the same resource so after a
while after you've depleted this
resource it's it's a state called ego
depletion you've got less self-control
you're more prone to giving the
temptation and so like you basically
just said what you gonna share I'll
tweet that photo of myself in my
underwear what could go wrong so since
you brought up the esteemed Anthony
Weiner and his decision fatigue what
happens when we put important decisions
in the hands of politicians and in
particularly there's been a lot of never
waste a crisis type legislating does
that play into your thesis at all that
this sort of last
rush to do big things are we getting
high quality law as a result not only
not I mean either George Bush famously
said you know he called himself the
decider and that's what these guys do
all day long as make decisions and and
if you just keep doing that all day long
eventually you start making the only bad
ones and trying to make a lot of them
and trying them trying to make them late
at night it's sure why not call the call
girl and why not transfer from my own
bank accounts so it's traceable can you
go ahead and just kind of explain one of
the central scientific works that you
base your book around which people tend
to refer to as the marshmallow test
well the marshmallow test was was this
thing where kids would be four-year-olds
would be given a marshmallow it would be
said in front of them and and they would
be told that they could eat it but if
they waited 15 minutes they would get
two marshmallows the kids who had
managed to resist the marshmallow they
did much better in school they did
better in life and that's that's what
kind of kicked off the modern self
control movement by accident until then
researchers hadn't really been focusing
on it much and then my co-author where
Baumeister did these famous experiments
with chocolate chip cookies and radishes
where he was looking for the source of
willpower and he found that you know
someone who sat there and had to resist
a chocolate chip cookie for five minutes
in a city radishes then later they would
give them a self-control test of this
puzzle and they would quit ten minutes
before someone else and so it had this
amazing effect and then and then they
found he found further that this of
course affected decisions and he also
found that there was a source of this
and glucose and in the bloodstream so
there was a whole finding what the
source of this was everyone's looking
for the source of the current financial
crisis it was the housing crisis caused
by people eating the cookie there's the
housing crisis I mean is that is this
something where we can say self-control
is related to these large-scale
phenomena or is it unrelated and that's
just how things go well there's two
failures and self-control they you know
they're the people who took out the
loans and was that really thinking
through can I actually afford this in
the future can I am I going to be making
enough money
they weren't you know setting realistic
goals and they weren't monitoring
themselves in the book we talked about
how you can use mint.com to do some of
this work for you but you have to be
realistic about your future and think
ahead and it's also caused by
politicians who wanted to appease their
constituencies and say I'm all for
affordable housing I'm gonna create
affordable housing to make sure people
can do it that's the great short-term
gratification for them but they're not
looking at the long-term consequences
you know can these people is forcing
banks to give loans to people who can't
afford them a really good long-term
policy if self-control can be taught who
should do the teaching parents can you
know can teach this at an early age and
it's one of the reasons that successful
parents tend to have successful kids
it's because the parents have
self-control and it takes self-control
to instill it you know you've got to set
you know set clear goals for the child
and then and then be consistent in
rewarding their success and in punishing
failure it doesn't have to be a strict
punishment but it should be consistent
and that's hard I mean as a parent I
know that it's much easier to let stuff
slide and it's the parents who can
really do this in the book we we I
talked to at a nanny Deb of nanny
nine-one-one how she does it like she
really uses the techniques that you know
that Roy has been studying that other
researchers have the other option I
suppose is after were adults you could
do what Drew Carey who features
prominently in your book did which is to
hire a consultant for a year in fact the
consultant on getting things done can
you kind of describe how that went and
it was great you know drew had read
getting things done by David Allen and
he would try to implement this system
called GTD which a lot of people tried
and and he was having mixed success so
he just thought I'm rich I can do this
so he hires David Allen to come once a
month and sit at his desk and go through
and clear his inbox and it worked for
him and if you simply make a plan to
deal with that then your unconscious
will let you go and then you're free but
if you don't if it's kind of like on a
vague thing I know I have to do it or if
you've got this vague idea on your to-do
list like do taxes but you can't really
do taxes in one step and what David
Allen and GTD did was try to break
everything down to it
doable to-do list and I've started using
and I have to say that I do have a
pretty pretty clear inbox and it does
free you up to write that way how did
you apply the tips and tricks of
willpower to writing book about
willpower well I am a lifelong
procrastinator I have rarely turned
things in on deadlines certainly never
before and my columns have always been
you know at the last minute this and we
managed to get this thing done two
months early you know the bad news today
is it there more temptations than ever
you can goof off any second of the day
and no matter where you are but there
are these new tools that will
automatically keep track of things for
you you can even arrange for them to
email your your spouse or your boss and
tell them what you've been doing I
haven't gone that far yet
but but there are these great new tools
for you know for enforcing self-control
and it's basically way of outsourcing
self-control and I think that's probably
a better deal than outsourcing it to the
government thank you very much John for
reason TV I'm Katherine Maggie ward
[Music]
you